the portsmouth coast where below this
beach
a planned new electricity cable linking
the uk grid to france would make
landfall
sometimes this beach is packed but the
akwind interconnector has proved
controversial here
with the council the city's mps and many
residents against it
it's just too much disruption the
pollution levels you know the
densely populated city the wildlife
where it's going
you know all these elements just just
don't add up to it being
you know suitable for this area at all
those behind the plan
say it will increase renewable energy
uptake and have little visual impact
that's because most of the cabling will
run underground from a sub-station
inland
beneath portsmouth and then 120 miles
out to france beneath the channel seabed
but it's not just the possible impact
here on the south coast
that's causing concern there are also
questions about the man behind the
project
businessman and conservative party donor
alexander tomerko
since arriving from russia and gaining
british citizenship
mr tamerko has cultivated extensive
political links
and supported dozens of tory mps both
directly
and through his firm former business
secretary alex sharma stepped away from
the aquin decision
after accepting ten thousand pounds from
the company
energy minister anne-marie trevelyan has
also received thousands
and business minister lord callanan used
to be an aquin director
money has also been given to cabinet
ministers brandon lewis and simon hart
as well as senior mp jeremy hunt and the
position of the current business
secretary has been questioned by labour
after emails were published apparently
showing his support for the scheme
there's no suggestion of any wrongdoing
and while alexander tomerko was not
available for interview
aquin did invite us to speak to one of
the firm's other directors
you've got one business minister that
used to be a director another another
minister at that department that has had
donations from akwind
the former business secretary had to
recuse himself
because he had had donations as well you
can see how people think this looks a
little bit cozy
well yeah i mean i can but you know
we don't if we don't see any link
between you know making a political
contribution to the conservative party
and what we're doing as a project
absolutely not you know we've received
no favors
from any party you know it's been an
uphill struggle
all the way business secretary quasi
cuateng will make the final decision on
the project
the government told us his previous
email about aquind
was not to do with the approval process
and that the two ministers with links to
the firm would not play a role in that
decision
russia experts say wealthy exiles like
alexander tamerko
see the current government as an ally
for their commercial interests
they see the conservative party as the
party of power
and having come from russia and having
grown up in the soviet union
you know they know that proximity to the
party of power being
in with the party of power is never
really a bad thing to be
if approved the link here would provide
millions of homes with electricity
and be a critical and profitable piece
of infrastructure
a case of connections and power in every
sense
rob powell sky news in portsmouth